Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to talk about an amazing
new technique to make these beautiful, but
very expensive computer simulations cheaper. How
much cheaper? Well, I will tell you in a moment.
You see, around here, we discuss research
papers like this and this. We talk a great
deal about how difficult and computationally
expensive it is to simulate all this physics,
but that’s not the only thing that needs to
be done here. All this data also has to be
stored too! That is a ton of geometry
information. How much exactly? Well,
15 gigabytes for a simulation is not uncommon, and
my fluid simulation that you see here took well
over a hundred gigabytes of space to store.
Some of the more extreme examples can fill
several hard drives for only a minute of physics
simulation data. That is an insane amount of data.
So, we need something to help compressing down all
this data. And the weapon of choice for working
with this kind of volumetric data is often a
tool called OpenVDB. It has this hierarchical
structure within, and scientists at NVIDIA had a
crazy idea. They said, how about exchanging this
with all of these amazing learning-based methods
that you are hearing about everywhere? Well,
okay, but why just throw a neural network at
the problem? Is this really going to help?
Well, maybe. You see, neural networks have
exceptional compression capabilities. For
instance, we have seen with their earlier paper
that such an AI can help us transmit video data
of us by, get this: only taking the first image
from the video, and just a tiny bit of extra data,
and they throw away the entire video afterwards!
So, can these techniques do some more magic in
the area of physics simulations? Those are
much more complex, but who knows, let’s see!
And now, hold on to your papers, because it
looks like this. Now that is all well and good,
but here is the kicker, it takes about 95% less
storage than the previous method. Yes, that is 20x
compression while the two pieces of footage still
look the same. Wow. That is absolutely incredible.
And the previous OpenVDB solution
is not just for some hobby projects,
it is used in many of the blockbuster
feature-length movies you all know and
love. These movies won many-many academy
awards. And, we are not done yet. Not
even close - it gets even better! If you
think 20x is the best it can do, now look,
we also have 50x here. And sometimes, it
gets up to even 60x smaller. My goodness!
And this new NeuralVDB technique from NVIDIA
can be used for not only these amazing movies,
but for everything else OpenVDB was
useful for. Oh yes! That means that
we can go beyond these movies, and use it for
scientific and even industrial visualizations.
They also have the machinery to read and
process all this data with a graphics card,
therefore it not only decreases the
memory footprint of these techniques,
but it even improves how quickly they run. My
mind is officially blown. So much progress in
so little time. And this is my favorite kind
of research, and that is when we look into the
intersection of computer graphics and AI. That’s
where we find some of the most beautiful works.
And don’t forget, these applications are
plentiful. This could also be used with
FourCastNet, which is a physics model that
can predict outlier weather events. The
coolest part about this work is that
it runs not in a data center anymore,
but today, it runs on just one NVIDIA
graphics card. And with NeuralVDB,
it will require even less memory to do
so. And it will help with all of these
absolute miracles of science that you see
here too. So, all of these could run with
an up to 60 times smaller memory footprint?
That is incredible. What a time to be alive!
Huge congratulations to Doyub Kim, the first
author of the paper and his team for this amazing
achievement. And once again, you see the power of
AI, the power of the papers, and tech transfer at
the same time. And, since NVIDIA has an excellent
record in putting these tools into the hands of
all of us, for instance, they did it with the
previous incarnation of this technique, NanoVDB,
I am convinced that we are all going be able to
enjoy this amazing paper soon. How cool is that?
So, does this get your mind going? What would you
use this for? Let me know in the comments below!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!